Never tell a story without a point, and
never make a point without telling a
story.
This was a quote I heard from Valerie
Garcia, who is an incredible keynote
speaker, and it's one of my favorite
quotes that I've heard when it comes to
public speaking, and it reiterates the
idea that storytelling is such an
essential part of any speech. And in
this YouTube video, I am going to give
you five of my favorite quotes that I
have received from keynote speakers that
encapsulates what it takes to give a
great presentation. You're going to want
to watch all the way to the end because
these five quotes could dramatically
impact how well your next speech goes.
Public speaking is an art form.
This was a quote from an interview I had
with Swish Goswami, who is a keynote
speaker who joined me on an episode of
Keys from Keynotes. And what this
suggested is that even though speeches
can have formalities and structures, and
every speech has a intro and a middle
and a conclusion or an ending,
it there's still the ability for you to
be creative within that speech and to
add creative interesting elements. And
so when you start to think about the
opportunity to give a presentation as an
actual art form, that really opens up
the endless possibilities of what you
can do as a speaker. The next quote I
love comes from a speaker named Shawn
Kanungo, who talks about the fact that
there are certain things that might be
beyond your control as a speaker. And
one of those is the room dynamics. You
see, it may be very challenging if you
have a small audience that's in a
massive room like this to make them
laugh, even though you present the exact
same material that you presented on a
different day in a smaller more packed
room that went over really well. And
Shawn talks about the fact that the
energy in a room with high ceilings that
spread out, it sort of dissipates and
it's hard to build that laughter amongst
the audience. This is why comedy clubs
often have the low ceilings and
everyone's packed in because it traps
that energy and it bounces off of
everything and it creates this momentum
of laughter amongst the crowd.
So, you should know as a speaker that
not every room is going to receive your
message the exact same even if you do a
great job delivering it.
But once you know that, it takes a
little bit of the pressure off of
yourself. I was blown away when I had a
conversation with Giselle Ugarte on an
episode of Keys from Keynotes, which is
my podcast that focuses all on keynote
speaking. And what Giselle told me was
that
she gets incredibly nervous before every
presentation.
And she is someone who is paid
quite a bit of money to go and deliver
her presentations at conferences
throughout North America and she's a
professional at what she does.
But it got to the point where she
explained before a lot of these speaking
events, she often spends about an hour
frozen with fear in her hotel room. And
she can't get out of bed and she's
overcome with these nerves and then
finally, just before she's about to take
the stage, she switches into this mental
state that gives her the confidence and
the ability to get on stage and to do
her thing and to crush it and she gets
excited about it.
But that only happens a few moments
before she takes the stage where it's
hours of dealing with the nerves.
And so, if this is how a professional
speaker, like Giselle, experiences it, I
think that that should take a little bit
pressure of pressure off of you if you
do experience those nerves or anxiety
because it's important to know that even
the pros get nervous. This is part of
it. But once we know our nervous
tendencies, that's where we can be
prepared and it becomes a lot more
predictable. One of my favorite quotes
about public speaking came from Savio
Asci Sengupta, who is the 2015, sorry,
the 2025
Toastmasters International World
Champion. And I never heard it described
this way before, but Savi talked about
Toastmasters
as sort of being like a playground.
And he said, "It is that sandbox
environment where you can experiment
and you can try things out and you are
in front of a safe space, a safe
audience who wants you to succeed.
And I think practice is the single most
important thing to improve your public
speaking skills. And if we think of
Toastmasters as that place to practice,
to put in the reps, but also a
playground to challenge ourselves, to
experiment with different mediums,
there is a ton of value of joining a
local Toastmasters club. And my final
favorite quote when it comes to public
speaking came from Mohammad Qahtani. And
Mohammad was the 2015 Toastmasters World
Champion. And he has this incredible
story of how he had a stutter as a child
that was so bad and he was so nervous
about it, he would never speak up in
class.
But he had a friend who challenged him
to go and read the school announcements.
And it was humiliating. He was made fun
of every single day, but he kept
challenging himself and pushing himself
to do it. And in my conversation with
Muhammad, he talked about the importance
of facing our fears, especially when it
comes to public speaking. And the fact
that when you do it, it's not going to
be easy. It's going to be very
challenging, but the more reps you put
in, the more you get right in front of
it, it's going to eventually, over time,
get easier and easier and easier.
And who better to give that example than
somebody who was frozen in fear about
stuttering, who went on to become the
world's best public speaker. I hope this
video on some of my favorite quotes from
professional keynote speakers has added
value to you.
If you're somebody who's a professional
or an executive and you want to get more
serious about your public speaking
skills, check out my stand store link
below and see how we can work together
in private one-on-one sessions.
Also, check out the video that is
popping up on your screen right now,
which YouTube is recommending. And if
you could subscribe to my channel, that
is the best way to help me create more
of this content. Thanks so much. Have a
great day.